today we're going to look at Egyptian
fractions and by that I do mean the
ancient Egyptians they worked base 10
like we do um so they had symbols and
I'm going to attempt to draw some
hieroglyphs so their symbol for the
number one is this groundbreaking it's
called a single stroke so if they wanted
to say two they combin two of these um
for 10 in hieroglyphs they have this
which I believe is called a cattle
hobble which I think was used you maybe
put it around cattle legs to slow them
down I looked into it don't really know
what that does but this is a 10 which is
a far more interesting use of it for 100
and now I'm almost definitely going to
get this the wrong way around but I
think it's this way and it's a coil of
rope I'm pretty sure it's that way round
someone will correct me if it's not for
1,000 this is when it gets slightly more
complicated and I've got to use my art
GCSE it is the water lily for 10,000 a
bent finger that looks vaguely like this
and that's a bent finger okay bent
finger 100,000 obviously whenever I
think of 100,000 what I think of is Tad
Pooles so this is a tab pole and now
finally a million and this really is
going to be putting my ass girls to use
a million is he now he is the
personification of Eternity or Infinity
so a million also kind of just means an
eternal or infinite amount which isn't
actually unheard of in cultures that we
have things like this um some people
believe that a,1 Arabian Knights
actually is meant to mean Infinity in a
bit more so the idea of there being a
very large number meaning that number or
Infinity is actually not an uncommon
idea at all so these are the Egyptian
hieroglyphs for powers of 10 and if you
wanted to maybe say you wanted to write
I don't know 23 what You' do is you
would write two t and a three and you
just combine them like that so now on to
fractions um I'm going to be talking
about I'm getting technical here earlier
Egyptian fractions so there is actually
evidence that fractions were done
slightly different later on there's a
famous Papyrus called the Rin
mathemathical Papyrus what we're going
to be talking about is earlier um when
fractions were all done by having a
mouth symbol like this and then a number
underneath so you might say this and
what this would be is is a tenth because
it's the mount symbol over 10 now with
this we can only get numbers fractions
with one in the numerator in fact there
are only two exceptions um to this so we
can have 2/3 which is like this and then
there is also 3/4 and a half for some
reason is different but aside from that
all others are of the form 1 / n so it
begs a question how is this useful what
happens if we have another another
fraction what happens if we have say 5
six well
56 is going to be just a half plus a
thir so actually we can still do this
now with Egyptian fractions which is
what these are called all the
denominators have to be different should
we try another one
1536 is going to be a thir is
1236 and that leaves
336 which is equal to a 12 so so far
looks like we can do it the question is
can we always do it so for this I want
to introduce you to the greedy algorithm
we've got our fraction p over q and
we're going to say p is not one because
we know if p is one we can do it we'll
just write it as is and the greedy
algorithm looks at the largest 1 / n
such that 1 / n is less than p q and we
start by just taking away this 1 / n
what do we know about this this is going
to be positive because we know this is
less than this so we'll end up with pnus
Q over qn which is positive okay we can
actually write an expression for n as
well we could write n is the ceiling
function of Q over P so it means it's
the smallest integer Above This fraction
ah we haven't actually used the fact
that 1 / n is the greatest for which
this is true cuz what this means is that
P Q is also going to be less than 1 /
nus one so we've said that this is going
to be the smallest such n or the largest
such one/ n they're the same thing
that's less than this hence we have this
inequality too now from
this we can multiply this out and then
we get that for example P * nus1 is less
than q and if we substitute this in we
get that PN minus Q is strictly less
than p and we already know it's positive
remember so we've started with p over Q
we've taken away 1 / n and now we've
ended up with a new fraction we'll call
it P1 over q1 such that P1 is less than
P now if P1 is one we're done because
then we could just say that P over Q is
1 / n plus P1 over q1 and if P1 is 1
we're done if not we just repeat this
process so we can then say that okay
let's find the largest such 1 over n the
smallest n that we get P1 over q1 it's
greater than one over let's call it N1
and less than this and we just repeat
and then we'll end up with P1 over q1
take 1/ N1 = P2 over Q2 and again we'll
have okay that 0 is less than P2 is less
than P1 we can substitute back in get p
over Q is 1 / n + 1/ N1 plus then this
will be P2 over Q2 and again if P2 is
one we're done if not we repeat it again
um so this is why it's called an
algorithm it's a series of steps and
what we're going to end up having is Zer
is less than p r for some R is less than
and it just keeps going less than P but
these are all integers these are all
positive numbers we can't have it going
down infinitely one of these is
eventually we're going to have to hit
one and the way we've constructed these
cues they're all going to be different
as well hence this process is eventually
going to terminate but yeah eventually
we're going to get a PR that equals one
so we're going to have P / Q is 1 / n +
1 / N1 plus plus 1/ then QR and we're
going to be done So eventually this
process does stop so this greedy
algorithm means that there isn't always
an Egyptian fraction okay there's one
final cool thing that I want to share
with you because here you remember we we
used a greedy algorithm where we took
the biggest 1 / n so n was n was this
value now if we slightly change this if
we slightly cheat and instead use the n
is Q over p + 1 and I'm going to show
you this for one so 1 equals well here Q
over P it's 1 over 1 so Q over p is
going to be 1 + 1 is 2 so that's a half
and then what we're going to do with our
half this is our new p over Q so Q over
p 2 over 1 is 2 2 over 1 + 1 is 3 so
it's a half plus a thir what remains is
six and we can keep following this
algorithm we get a half plus A3 plus it
be a 7th + 1
43 plus and so on this is the cool thing
as well because here if at any point we
trate it it gives the Egyptian fraction
closest to one for that many that many
terms so a half is the Egyptian fraction
with one term closest to one a half plus
a thir is the Egyptian fraction with two
terms closest to one a half plus a third
plus a sth is the Egyptian fraction with
three terms closest to one and I just
think it's really
cool I love that there are so many
courses on brilliant and always new ones
being added look here I've spotted this
recent Edition on vectors so well I
thought I'd check it out in typical
fashion it's quirky welld designed and
super interactive I'm not just watching
I'm
doing all the courses the quizzes the
content on brilliant is just like this
it's a great place to learn it doesn't
feel like education it just it feels
like fun but I'm learning at the same
time if you haven't already you might
want to consider signing up and getting
into all this good stuff or perhaps give
the gift of brilliant by signing up
family and friends for the premium
subscription what a great and unexpected
present wherever they are on their
Learning Journey brilliant has something
for everyone math science computers it's
all covered now brilliant has a free
30-day trial so you can go and give it a
good go and number five viewers can get
a 20% discount on their subscription by
going to brilliant.org
numberfire that URL is there on the
screen and I'll also put a link in the
video description now thanks to
brilliant for supporting number
[Music]
far so my favorite number changes a lot
but for now it is
288 you might be looking at that and
thinking what's special about 288 don't
worry we'll get there but first we need
to rewind a bit and talk a bit about
factorials specifically super factorials
now I know regular number five viewers
will have seen factorial before